in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Wes and
Kelly are with us hey guys how are ya
all right
welcome welcome where you guys from
Indianapolis Indiana cool
welcome to Nashville and how much debt
have you paid off
we paid off $47,000 all right how long
did that take 15 months good job and
your range of income during that time
started off about 50 ended that period
about 110 okay so in less than two years
you doubled your income tell me how that
happens I went back to work oh okay
that'll do it what do you do I'm a labor
and delivery nurse okay very cool good
for you and Wes what do you do I'm in
the army
oh well thank you for your service thank
you for your paying your taxes I ain't
done no choice yet so what kind of debt
was the forty seven thousand it was
student loans and one car loan okay what
happened 15 months ago that made you
guys get on this journey January of 2015
we were sitting down to do our tax
return and we had tried to pay off debt
casually since the beginning of our
marriage and we just looked at what we
had made that year and realized we have
made no progress we have to get on a
plan we have to start doing this for
real and then a friend at work gave me
the CDs to listen to and then in April
of 2015 we really started gizelle
intends did the cash envelopes all that
okay all right so you were listening to
the CDs and was Wes listening to him too
or you're listening to him and you're
translating she was yeah she was
interpreting so she's saying I was these
cities we got to do this stuff and what
were you saying um I was not on board
for quite a while so okay what got you
on board that's a great question I think
just listening to the podcast at home I
would just listen to it a lot okay yeah
cuz she would play it on the car from
Fort Bragg to Indianapolis that's like a
good nine hours we
listen to you yeah you can't get away
that while you're in a trap
you're trapped okay Wow
well very cool though eventually that'll
wear you down yeah I love it so what do
you tell people the key to paying off
$47,000 and 15 months is I think just
deciding to start get on the plane
obviously what we did was not working
the casual we should pay off debt we
should get out of you know these student
loans in the car but just going about it
casually was not working so we said okay
let's just try it let's what we're doing
isn't working so let's try something
different
it worked do something different than
what we're doing if we want a different
result they can't do the same thing over
and over again expect a different result
that's called insanity yeah good for you
guys very cool okay what was the hardest
part of this for you - my hardest part
was cutting up the credit cards
yeah it's 2% is hard to pass up
sometimes but those that was mine yeah
and then in the classic like I had first
so long been like we have to get rid of
the credit cards like we're gonna do
this we have to do that part - and he
just was not on board he's a he's a math
nerd but he's the free spirit so that
was kind of hard to reconcile but we
ended up coordinating the class there
wasn't a class in our area so we
coordinated it and went through it for
the first time oh wow so during the
class he came to me and said okay I
think it's time it's hard to teach
something if you're not doing it yeah
yeah very cool well good for you guys
well done how's it feel pretty good it's
a pretty dadgum impressive thing I mean
47 thousand bucks in 15 months you
knocked it out
that's about what three grand a month
you're popping that right very serious
very well done
you going back to work had a lot to do
with it was that a hard decision it was
and that was the hardest part for me was
he would work you know during the week
long hours he was gone 12 hours a day
and then he comes home Friday night and
I hand off the kids and I go to work I
work nights well I did I've staying home
now but I was working nights and that
was hard to just pass off the kids and
say see I'd come home in the morning and
sleep and he'd have the kids and I'd go
to work again that night so that was
that was the hardest part but so worth
it to be where we are now
you know I'll show you you've dropped
back you've dropped them yeah okay that
was just to get out of that okay Wow and
how old are the kids
they are three 20 months and two months
Oh little ones okay and their names
Emilia Olivia and Griffin okay
are they gonna help with our debt free
screen here okay good they've been
practicing all the way from Indianapolis
at least a couple of them have anyway
okay very good
all right we're gonna give you a copy of
Chris Hogan's retire inspired book which
this is the next step for you guys is to
retire inspire to build some wealth and
that'll be part of the deal because
that's the next part of your story all
right Wes and Kelly Amelia Olivia and
Griffin $47,000 paid off in 15 months
making 50 to 110 now back to 50 count it
down let's hear a debt free scream three
two one way to go
sighs very well done
you kids hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
the common